[Music]
this may look like the kind of battery
you'd find in the back of your TV remote
but it's actually an electric vehicle
battery thousands of these going to the
heart of every EV now no matter where in
the world that electric vehicle was made
there's a strong chance that the battery
inside was made in China but America is
trying to change that see President
Biden has signed legislation that
encourages U.S car manufacturers to
Source batteries that have been made in
America the problem is that right now
not many of those made in America
batteries exist and that's because
Mining and production happens elsewhere
so what currently goes into America's
batteries and what's it going to take
for the country to ramp up production
well let's crack One open and find out
foreign
so I've come to ucl's electrochemical
Innovation lab because I want to break
down the individual components of a
battery and I've seen what happens when
you try and do that at home
yeah no fortunately researcher Dr Mark
buckwell has started safely dismantling
one for me in a sealed environment hey
Mark hi George yeah
I'll pick your hand but you're a bit
tied up so what's going on here so here
we have begun the disassembly process
for some lithium-ion cells you've got a
steel casing surrounding all of these
very thin layers of material and you can
see there the rolled up structure it's
really tightly packed and this is the
kind of battery that you'd find in a
Tesla yeah is this kind the most recent
Tesla batteries are a bit bigger once
Mark has completely removed the outer
shell we're able to unroll the layers
I'm most interested in the anode and
cathode there you can see the anodes
this is a copper foil with graphite on
it in between two layers of separator we
have the cathode this is actually
aluminum with the lithium-containing
metal oxide on it's the movement of
lithium ions between these two layers
that allow batteries to store and
release energy
now our battery's been broken down I
want to know what kind of minerals go
into it and where Mining and assembly
happens so Mark has handed me over to Dr
Paul shearing so the cafe material that
we've got here involves nickel and
manganese and Cobalt and lithium and
oxygen you've got to understand a really
complicated supply chain of all those
different minerals often coming from
very different geographies
around 55 of the world's lithium mine
production is in Australia and the vast
bulk of the world's Cobalt comes from
the Democratic Republic of the Congo
once the minerals have been mined
they're turned into anodes and cathodes
and that is where China starts to
dominate the final step is to package
those anodes and cathodes into finished
batteries while the US does account for
around seven percent of global battery
manufacturing it's nothing compared to
China which assembles a whopping 76
percent of the world's batteries so what
will it take for the us to bring all
stages of that production onto its
Shores well to find out I called my
colleague amrith Ram Kumar who covers
climate finance and he told me that
America isn't exactly short of the
minerals it needs to make batteries the
US has a good amount of lithium deposits
and other natural resources but getting
the permits and all the other
permissions needed to mine them and
process them is very difficult it's
really not feasible to get the supply
chain off the ground before or later
this decade I told so unlikely that the
US will be able to significantly ramp up
its anode and Cafe production anytime
soon China has so many years dominating
that supply chain again that it's very
hard for companies in the U.S and Europe
and elsewhere to just up and say hey
we're going to try to compete now when
costs are much higher and they don't
have as much experience doing it but
where the us could make some Headway is
it increasing its battery assembly
capacity as companies like LG chem catl
and Panasonic are working with U.S
automakers to build large plans in the
US even if those plants are built
they're going to have to be huge to make
a dent on China's dominance and keep up
with America's growing demand for
batteries that means it's likely going
to take time and billions if not
trillions of dollars for the majority of
America's EV batteries to be 100 made in
the USA
foreign